[Music]
all right we're gonna go out with a bang
today with with a question that
everybody on the streets is always asked
him selves or what about jobs um Eric
green no son and his brain panelists are
not just gonna punt by talking about
tomorrow they're gonna say well what if
we actually get a GI that can do
everything all our jobs cheaper and
better than we can then how do we get
income how do we get meaning how do we
get purpose in our lives take it away
thanks max so let me let me just say
that you know when I was in grad school
economics was taught to me is the study
of scarcity and Max's premise is that
we'll have a GI so I don't know we you
know that annoying saying there is no
free lunch maybe that will go away we'll
have not just free lunches free dinners
free coffee breaks any time at the beach
it'll be it'll be all courtesy of a GI
not FLI so thank you so that's one kind
of scenario but as we were talking it's
clear that's not the only kind of
scenario there's no economic law that
says even if you create more and more
abundance that everyone's going to get a
share of that it's perfectly possible
you get very uneven outcomes or you get
other kinds of of different outcomes so
we'll talk a little bit about that and
and ask what if anything is still scarce
and as Max said most of us will get our
income from jobs and if AG I can do
everything then that may be problematic
we also get a lot of our bargaining
power are the fact that we are
economically necessary gives us a lot of
leverage in society and if we are
superfluous
maybe we become at the mercy of people
who who don't need us anymore and that
that could be an issue and and then of
course there's questions of meaning and
purpose that many of us derive from the
work we do and there are other issues
that will come up as we do it so we had
this amazing panel here just once it
Gillian Hatfield James mineka and Reid
Hoffman and let me just start right off
by asking each of you this morning max
talked about some of the destinations so
I'd like to hear each of you say
something about imagine this world that
max positive for us of a world of AGI
what what sort of destination would you
envision what do you see as going in
that kind of world given that there are
different possibilities let's start with
you Julian so I think what we're trying
to imagine here is a world in which
humans are not necessary in order to
perform the productive work to produce
all the stuff that we survive on so the
question is what are humans doing if
they're not if they're not engaged in
jobs and I think the key thing here is
to think about the fact that well first
of all humans are gonna find lots of
things to do I think we have lots of
there are lots of times in the history
of humans when we have done things other
than produce productive do productive
work and I think the key thing is that
if we're doing a vision it's a vision of
the ways in which we connect with one
another and the communities and
preferably communities of choice that we
live in and so I think what we can
imagine is that these are contexts for a
meaningful shared activity that they are
context for the experience of being a
valued respected and cared for member of
a community they can be vehicles for the
distribution of resources because even
if we don't have to produce stuff it
still needs to be resources there needs
still needs to be distributed and
settings in which we can experience that
we talked about actually with Yahshua's
group yesterday the fair process of
collective decision making because there
will still be choice and things to be
decided and things to be done so I'm I'd
like a vision of healthy constructive
meaningful life through communities but
the market sort of fades away well I
think that that that may well be that
may well be true and I think it's
important to think of this and I think
Josh green mentioned the concept of the
arc of economic history and social
history and
been lots of times in human life where
we don't have anything that resembles
something called a job we may be doing
sound too bad
I love the smiley because I know I know
you can imagine other scenarios read
that's what you're thinking so I mean
there is one kind of happy Star Trek
neutral universe I don't know if I can
imagine human beings that aren't
actually in fact in at least partial
conflict with each other okay if I look
back on the history as I understand it
and I also a fan of Robert Wright's
nonzero book the you know the tension is
that there's always essentially
conflicts about you know who's in
control who has more power or who has
more status you know who is you know
more powerful within the unique and
within the kind of almost any invented
unique attributes and so a part of the
benefit of the system we have today is
we have a broad system of of essentially
kind of codependency where we have to
essentially work together and have it be
broadly in the direction of more
collaborative and more peaceful because
of economic codependence now if that
goes away it's a little curious as to
what happened and so for example if you
consider you know what happens if you
leave a lot of teenagers or young people
to themselves what do they do right and
what happens in that context and so and
they've got abundant
yeah and presume that they have a
sufficient abundance so what do they do
and you know the answer may be a lot of
vandalism or other you know kind of
gang-related behavior or other kinds of
things which it may not be our optimum
StarTAC utopia and so I tend to think
that when I kind of think about
sketching utopia I tend to think and the
fractious nature of human beings I tend
to think that we want to deliberately
create areas by which we are involved in
these cooperating and competing games
together in a way that we express more
of what we hope for from humanity
and we have less you know kind of
free-ranging okay well I'll just a j't
eight to break the system because if the
system doesn't give me a path to do that
that I will actually work to break the
system well it's very striking because
there's a very common story that you
know we're always fighting with each
other over resources you know fighting
over land or oil or whatever and if only
we could have you know more resource
constraints those problems would go away
and you're almost saying the opposite
yeah I actually think that it's it I
love this I think that when you there's
a lot of theories we say we got to
increase the bunch you get increase in
disparity I think as far as I can tell
like a lot of people who pursue money
don't think oh I only get X money and
I'm gone I'm done they're looking for a
lot more money are you done well I would
say that I mean I'm a kind of definition
of what some people call post economic
and I would say that in terms of
influence our ability to try to help the
world in certain ways no well thank you
for being here with James can you and
you reconcile these or go beyond them
well I think you can reconcile them but
also creative the bunch of questions for
how we should think about is if you take
what what Julian and what readers just
said and you think about it and put it
in the context of economic history you
look at what humans have done that is
economic in nature cuz we're having an
atomic discussion it's always has been
an interplay of three specific thing one
is something wrong scarcity talked about
that you know who has access to them who
owns them who controls them etc
scarcities have played a big part of our
human activity the other one is just
when humans then organize and put
together factory inputs to produce
something factors of production with its
capital labor to produce some output or
theirs to feed themselves and that gets
to the third thing which is there's
always demand for those outputs now
those demands either to feed themselves
consume themselves or have someone who
can pay for them or somebody to exchange
them with so you have to have all three
elements that's how we've organized
society for the most part and
look at communities even pre-industrial
that's what they did that's what they
did and so the benefit so with AGI we
change all three elements mm-hmm if we
get to the first one is kind of the root
of the other two I think it's the root
to the other two but the other two are
also important because they've played a
role like the second one the organizing
factors of production that's what human
beings have ended up doing when people
go to work or when they go farming or
they grow vegetables they're doing the
second thing to produce some to produce
something that they'll eat themselves or
consume or whatever happening so a judge
changes all three things but I think
before we get to the scenarios I think
it's also important to recognize that
how beneficial all of this has been
right if you think about how communities
to Julian's point have emerged other
than kinship communities all the other
committees have been in pursuit of
subversion of these three things either
they're organizing to grow something or
to go hunting together or to create
something in exchange with somebody and
that's created that's been the basis of
survival but also prosperity but also
the rewards and ultimately the power
that societies have had so when you take
all of that away then you left with okay
hopefully a world of abundance they do
not have these distributional questions
that you now have to deal with one
analogy that might be useful to think
about is think about I guess the only
examples we've had of abundance a
limitless abundance have been rich
people you know aristocracy or whatever
in history what are they ended up doing
right there will never be there
in a good sense becoming you know
gentlemen and there were men gentlemen
scientists amateur scientists or I think
it was a renaissance or exactly or
they've gone exploring right or they're
pursued power and control for whatever
reason and right so that's what they end
up doing now again mr. cup of those are
related to economic activity but the
worrying thing is that you may end up
where weed was which is all you're left
with if a just solves all these other
things all the economic parts of that
then you're left with competition or
other behaviors that are necessarily
productive so the question is what does
that does that lead us to a good outcome
or not so on the questions and then also
the question is what's cast is - what
are the what are what are gonna be the
real scarcities in a job I want to come
to that in real scarcity one but I want
to give Jillian a chance to respond a
little bit because it's a little
surprising I think to a lot of people
that they're James and Reed don't see a
world of abundance of one as less
conflict and you described a kind of
really nice world where we're
cooperating more in groups but but how
do you respond to these other concerns
well I think so I was I was laying out
what's a what's a I think a potentially
attainable hopeful vision of the world
but I do think the future has a ton of
politics in it because I think that
probably more actually if you've got
more time I think humans will I think we
will cooperate to find meaning to
construct meaning but we will also
continue to construct I'm more important
than you I am entitled to more than you
we still haven't figured out how to
distribute the benefits of the
Industrial Revolution to almost
three-quarters of the planet so I think
that although I so I don't actually
think that we are facing a world of you
know we'll have lots of stuff everybody
will get along will be nice to everybody
I don't think that's the case I think
the real challenge is can we come up
with the mechanisms and the structures
in which we invent better ways to
accomplish this or that but I do think
there again Josh Green mentioned this
sort of that the continual progress in
terms of figuring out how to cooperate
over broader groups yeah I think having
communities choice is an important part
of but I think the question for us and I
totally agree with that Jillian the
question is if you take you know Josh's
history and that's economic history
which is the basis of that cooperation
for the most part has been economic in
some form of fashion
we're exchanging things we're working
together to create something when those
are when those communities in of
cooperation being anything other than
kinship communities they've been largely
economic so in a world which the
economic motivations are not only some
parents aren't there anymore
what's the
for the community that's what I think
there's this there's this famous quote
from Adam Smith I love it he says we may
get this law wrong maybe but he says
it's not from the benevolence of the
butcher the baker or the brewer that we
get our meat bread or beer it's because
they're looking out for their own
self-interest so that leads to cooperate
maybe if you take away that that benefit
from cooperation would things be worse I
get I think I want to challenge the idea
that the only reason people come
together to cooperate in groups is to
produce economic I do think that has
been an incredibly important driver and
it's incredibly important driver I think
Reid is right about that they're
figuring out how not to fight so much
right because we can be more productive
but we come together in research
societies we come together in religions
we form bands we dance together
we go out to the desert and we do a lot
of other things together and I think
that if we don't have to be aware I
don't ever plan on retiring because I
don't even understand what that means
that would be the sad part if I had to
not do what I do now because I had to do
something else to earn income oh let me
just come back to this question I
promise to come back to about air city
because I mean there are those I'm coach
john maynard keynes here he said that he
thought that the economic problem if we
look into the future is not the
permanent problem of the human race he
wrote that in 1930 he predicted that by
2030 that we would be have so much
abundance that the economic problem
would largely go away I don't know if
the timing is going to be quite right
but he define the economic well I'm
pretty narrowly to be that most of the
world I won't read the whole quote but
it was in a struggle for subsistence and
that you could imagine a world where we
have more than enough food clothing
shelter etc so suppose we posit the
sexual world which I mean if you look at
the Millennium Development Goals we
actually are blowing past some of the
goals that were set in 1990 in terms of
extreme poverty reduction and some
people predicted that extreme poverty
which is a low bar admittedly will be
eliminated by 20
30 or 20 35 but even if we assume such a
world
let me ask each of you what if anything
would be scarce in special world so I
think one of the predictions of what
what we scarce is I think compute is
gonna be scarce but I think that
infinite demand the jakers gonna go for
it I think that's a part of that's
happening within whatever wherever you
on the scope of AGI and and wherever
years I think that's going up I don't
know about matter energy conversion
stuff but I do think actually in fact
energy will also then get scarce because
like like compute there will be a demand
for energy I mean more or less what
we've seen in our histories whatever
economic energy you can create the
demand simply goes up to meet the energy
so I think the J curve and that's gonna
go up so I think it was gonna be that
and then most importantly when you get
to human beings I think there's a bunch
of relative Goods status control power
other kinds of things that will also be
important now I would also just note let
me say one more thing and then I you can
go back if I haven't answered it um I
wasn't meaning tone to be truly
pessimistic in my alternative vector
answer to how Jillian opened which is I
do think it's possible to shape things
that are a combination of competition
and cooperation that have utopic aspects
whether that's the highest utopia or not
I think is an interesting discussion but
like for example you say well say we
don't need to compete and cooperate for
economics anymore say food security
housing security clothing security it's
all 100% distributed we haven't as you
mentioned even solve those distribution
problems yet let alone the future but
you could still say ok well who are who
are the best entertainers who are the
best philosophers who are the best
theorists who are the best like a whole
set of different kinds of things may
still create a competition and compete
landscape that if we can get enough of
humanity bought into you might create a
stable system that has utopic aspects
even though the are we competing because
we can't afford shelter or we can't
afford food may be possible yes just to
be real real sharp make sure I getting
that so there's
good like food building that you just
there's some absolute amount and you're
more or less satisfied and then there
are other goods that are relative and
it's sort of an ordinal ranking and you
know by definition there could only be
number one number one person and so
that's always gonna be scarce yes and so
you can still create a system around
that but hopefully if you get enough
people to buy in can have a much more
peaceful characteristics I was gonna
jump in which is maybe one of the things
that's important in this conversation is
to think about even what the conception
of AGI actually is because if we if it's
truly as expansive as we think it is and
its capabilities many of the things I
guess that we've come together as people
to do beyond even the economic it will
do create art create music create
empathy so if we truly take it to the
extreme where it's actually doing all of
those many of the things that then get
left over so to speak are not all good
or at least have unpredictable end so
you could argue religion you could argue
kinship tribal instincts of one sort or
another
so that's what I worry about now if our
conception of AGI is different meaning
okay so maybe you know I'll use one
example I'll take your Russell's right
in front of me it takes to us view of
these three principles that necessarily
has evolved with people because in fact
part of what we do in that system in
your view if we realize eight years
where you propose people are playing the
role of creating a mechanism to reflect
our preferences through other things so
we necessarily have a role but if the
AGI is totally in control
totally and creates all the outputs then
I think it's different so I think it's
hard to have this conversation that also
having some view of would you think what
the expansive nature of the aged people
might prefer artisanal products that
were certified human created even if
their quality was indistinguishable or
worse than the ones that were created by
machine did you imagine a more
for that yeah it's quite possible so so
for example so y'all remember we're
getting to the question so what job so
it's obviously the view that says well
maybe they'll be things we will
necessarily prefer them because of the
human role in creating them and we
prefer that better product or is an
outcome but just the fact that humans
created it come to value it we could
decide raising our children even though
you know there may be a safer system you
'men role in that so we can define
things that we value because of the
inherent role that humans have played in
them that's interesting I think that's
interesting life so you mentioned a
couple of things in this world of AGI
and perhaps material abundance are there
we heard about some scarce things are
there some things you imagined that jobs
will still exist or that there's some
other way of distributing income at you
let's hear from the other two panelists
are there still will there still be
anything like work or jobs so I think
thinking about things in terms of the
consumption value of products and jobs
is you know thinking about our economic
system as it is today and I think so
I don't even think we have to think
about will people prefer human-made art
music so on I say no but people will
want to relate to other humans in that
way they will want to produce those
things there are conversations and
things that we create and interactions
and relationships and games we play and
so on I think will continue to be
activities that we don't need to think
of them as producing consumption goods
people will do them like most people buy
gifts or just you know interacting with
each other
I was whether there were no money
involved I just don't want to sit around
with people and talk about things like
this not as a product but as an activity
so maybe thinking about it as jobs and
the production of goods maybe maybe too
narrow in terms of how resources and
income get distributed so if I think
about the danger of and we think about
some of the very currents the current
concept this day
with the we're already seeing it the
reduction in jobs and therefore high
levels higher levels of unemployment and
what do we see with that we see the real
danger there is the disconnection the
distaff equation the not not actually
being a part of a group so I think part
of the group notion is I should we need
those groups in order to be part of how
we connect with the rest of the world
and that may be the mechanism I want to
follow up on that but first but that's a
different type of money see if Reid has
anything he wants to add on the will
there still be jobs or work that people
do or something that looks like that so
I mean like entertainingly I wrote my
thesis at Oxford on the limits of
thought experiments and reasoning and so
when you engage in these kinds of very
speculative thought experiments I always
get worried especially when I'm doing it
the I guess what I'd say is I don't know
how to imagine a broadly more peaceful
society that doesn't involve some areas
where people are competing in various
ways or a sense of purpose or a sense of
of significance and that where that
sense of purpose comes with a reward
structure it doesn't know so you have to
come with a reward structure in terms of
physical goods but you may come in terms
of relative goods it could be like a
Shinto and we already live in a world
where we have a blend of things where
people do activities just because I'll
do them anyway because they think I'm
fascinated by this I love this I want to
create this I love hanging with these
kinds of people that sort of thing and a
bunch of I'm doing this because it it
gets me my relative position and etc and
we hope in as we make progress in
society that we move away from you know
fear of death fear starvation fear of
house homelessness fear of you know
threat of violence and so forth and we
evolve as a society and we get
absolutely as many people out of that as
possible but I still think we will find
some other it could be citations it
could be Twitter followers it could be
you know friends in your circle I mean
these are some of the other possible
ones so this
of fraxinus fractious competitiveness I
don't know how to imagine human beings
as we are today without that and so I
think you need to build that into your
system so now I'll come back to Gillian
and maybe James to about is that this Lu
is that how we get meaning if if people
lose their jobs as as truckers and coal
miners and whatever I and many of them
steam you know the deaths from despair
are taking off as case and Eden
described in part people think because a
lot of people have lost their their
economic meaning and purpose and feel
despair but but in Reed's scenario that
there's plenty of other ways to get
meaning we could can we we repurposed
our our goals well I say I think I I
think we will find those ways and the
key thing is can we provide the social
enormity of structure for people that
makes those healthy groups and not this
functional groups that protects people
against isolation and I think I going
back to the scarcity question it's
either a scarcity or a constraint I do
agree that you leave a bunch of humans
around for very long and then I'm gonna
start to say okay you don't get anything
all right I actually care a lot about
what you do it actually has no direct
impact on me but I don't want you doing
that thing right or you've got the wrong
color skin or you believe the wrong
things and I'm actually gonna interfere
with the way you're living your life I
think that continues to be a major risk
though I think a scarcity we face is our
capacity for managing and we've made a
lot of progress on that but we still are
limited and I I'd like to think we
talked about this as well you know you
know whether whether a I can help us
doing that
go ahead show maybe to build on that you
know maybe one of the ways to think
about that is to think about could we
specify a reward system or some kind of
conditions ubi that amplifies you know
are argue the the proxies that came from
the economic system was one of the
things that the economy economic system
does he created mechanisms for soften
provement incur in a way that encourage
that mechanisms for discovery or reap
motivating research mechanisms that
created codependence necessarily within
groups but also between groups because
without that are worried that the
communities that could emerge could be
based on more trivial and potentially
worrisome things that are mostly kinship
tribal but so could we artificially
build into the system
mechanisms for community that look like
maybe but for the economical let me put
you on the spot but look one of the arcs
might think about the conversation today
and this does apply to the jobs question
who is he said well should humanity be
in control and there are human beings
that I can think of I go oh good that'd
be good I can think of human beings I go
Oh God terrible so what is humanity and
control mean is one of these questions
that does apply to well what's the
system overall in terms of how are we
living together how are we whether it's
an individual focus that or yeah corner
unquote more Eastern focus or more
society focused or more path-dependent
focus look how do we get to that you
know kind of quality lives well and that
raises a question of power who who gets
to make these decisions I want to get
some questions from the audience in to
but but let me go back to change now you
have 30 seconds to think about a little
bit more what this conditional I guess
that's a toxic want conditional
unconditional basic income the
conditional basic income I mean how
would it how would it look in what are
the beauties of the market system at
least to economists like me is it's
relatively decentralized the
self-organizing could it be done in that
way or do you need to have some
government or central authority or set
up the rules well I think you'd want to
be stuff organizing in some fashion but
I think part of it is you know the
that's the work I think somebody has to
do right which is I'd wanted to
encourage some individual behaviors that
are mostly constructive stuff learning
self-improvement discovery all those
things and also want to encourage these
group behaviors that are product
cooperation or dependence
interdependence that then I think we
have a healthy outcome
now how we administer that or create
mechanisms so that I think that's
probably the the new economics to be
rented and thought about how do those
marketplaces work now there may be some
lessons to be learned from what we're
starting to see with rating systems and
other things to learn from systems of
some sort and that's what we have I've
heard him propose maybe this is the
perhaps too simple but straw proposal is
that a basic income could be conditional
on people learning particular skills and
so that it kind of encourages him to
constantly be up stealing and learning
new things yeah there's a by the way of
course which critics back to what the
aging looks like they told me in charge
where they decide the AGI of a guy's
decided the thing they want to keep us
around for whatever reason I could
imagine they could create Bank work for
us that exact in area well this is a
clever way to create a mechanism and
keep us doing make us feel like things
maybe that's what they're doing right
now
it's possible they wouldn't tell us how
do you encourage good behavior
right how do we encourage fair
cooperative behavior I think the way
humans have always done that is to
create groups that generate value and
then can create their own rules about
how we behave and you get kicked out of
the group if you if you don't and in
groups keep forming those and so I you
know I think posit we think of universal
basic income is something that goes to
individuals because it's replicating the
idea of the individual in a market but
maybe we should be thinking about
resources that are going to groups you
can be group in another group and that
group is making a decision and and I say
if these are groups that people can join
are you worried that that we already
have a lot of tribals
in our society and this would even just
give more and more incentive for people
to form these these groups of us versus
them I think it's a messy process we
have here we have our tribalism we also
have families and academic societies and
workplaces and
young people who don't hang out and want
to engage in vandalism I do want to save
the game we have young people who are
saying I want to make the world a better
place and I want to find other people
like me who want to make the world a
better and you see the net the words
your mouth words but you're emphasizing
I think the net benefits of these groups
or as opposed to some of those sounds I
think we're on a process that's figuring
out how do we get more of that kind of
group behavior and less of the other and
that's the great job so to the fourth
wall note of that but I think this were
we should go back to Josh point in the
sense that so what's the analog of trade
this world because if these groups are
self-contained and I also worry about
that but when they're trading and
exchanging something and they're
codependent for whatever reason that's
been around so what's the analog of
trading there's your answer I don't know
that's a good question this comes back
to the thought experiment stuff but a
lot of the creation of culture and
interaction tends to be where you think
from today's point of view one of the
problems with thought experiments is you
tend to think your imagine as much your
imaginations much more free-roaming
right and there's many things that you
can't imagine as they get there cause I
think the analogies here because that's
the best we can do is something that
exists but let me come back to a point
you made a little while ago about about
power and the AG I to siding because is
one of the concerns I have is that
whether it's a ubi or a conditional
basic income or whatever that through
all of history
we humans have been essential we've had
an economic role and the feudal lord or
the capitalist owner or whatever
couldn't do their stuff without us and
therefore that gave us a certain amount
of bargaining power they couldn't just
ignore us all or kill us all but if if
there's an AGI that can produce
everything it and it's you know it's by
its benevolence or maybe it's AGI run by
a small group of humans they give us the
AGI they give us the basic income
but it's really just because they feel
like it if they didn't want to they
wouldn't have to and we couldn't do
anything about it is that that seems
like a unstable or worrisome scenario
does that worry you guys or worries me
that's right I go back to unless you
build it the way stood once to build it
because there's an inbuild role for you
that model
well we declared there is but if
somebody if the people who are running
the AGI decide that these other humans
aren't needed anymore there's nothing
really stopping them doing that not in
the way that there was historically no
but you know for himself but at least
that we understand what you're proposing
is that there's a necessary societal
human role in shaping the values we
carry had a hard course then get
reflected but they're constantly
evolving so there's a constant interplay
as I understand it which in what we
humans want and so forth and what the
age doing so that there's a necessarily
inbuilt role for us in that system okay
it's declared that we have that power
okay anybody else want to comment to
that no I mean I think a lot of the
conference than the workshop have been
about the big big questions about you
know is it gonna be an agent is it gonna
be multiple agents what's the role for
humans does it have power over us and I
think one of the questions we're trying
to answer is it even if it's not what
does it look like and and so I sort of
am in ok think of it it's Eric's talked
about it like this you know it's a
technology and it's available to all so
that we can we can produce as much as we
want if the service that we want the
services model and then you say ok so
the real question then is do humans
still have meaningful lives I think they
will still try to gain power over each
other and we have to be figuring out how
to how to manage that and I think that's
what humans have had to do since the
beginning by my clock we saw a little
bit of time let's get some questions 30
seconds but ok go earlier panelists made
a point that I think is super important
is we and to
think that we are the current Nicole of
enlightenment you know because I was a
little bit like do you mean society by I
think it was like middle-aged you know
middle medieval you know European or
other folks and so forth and I actually
think one of the most mind-bending part
of this is try to figure out how if
you're presuming that is that don't
there's a dynamic of progress how you're
allowing that discovery process to
happen in the best possible way versus
the setting it now is I think one of the
criteria of design for what you're
looking yeah and me yeah right okay
Joshua so I want to come back to
something that was mentioned about
research requiring and economic
incentive I actually disagree with that
and a good example is academia which
produces a lot of knowledge and new
ideas and of course we have salaries and
so on but it's kind of like universal
basic income for professors in and very
for students but but it's kind of a
constant thing which doesn't you know
have much of a strong relationship with
our output and instead if you ask people
you know why they're doing it and why it
for example you know am I saying in
academia not doing to industry and many
other professors in computer science
we're not completely once we have enough
money we're motivated by other things
like the pleasure of producing new ideas
and and being part of a community I mean
like the communities of created by
researchers super important to our own
Worth and and meaning and it's not
necessarily coming from the economic
incentive I mean I mean so one version
is that you know citations and other
scarce things is the motivation another
version is that it's just the love of
knowledge and we wouldn't need any of
the extrinsic motivation we would just
do it and maybe maybe a third version is
is was related is sort of is it altruism
would you put weight on one or the other
of those as as the main driver of so I
think it depends on the social context
so if if you're in a community which is
valuing citations then suddenly it
becomes important for you because
you want to get to be rewarded by the
community but if you're in a group I've
seen groups working together where it
wasn't something in their mind but
rather the pleasure of you know creating
and doing things together and so on and
so it really depends how we want to set
it up I wasn't suggesting that they're
necessarily economic incentives for
everything I'm just saying that there
are activities that are largely economic
and offensively was being created or
this knowledge has value now whether
it's been monetized in dollars it's a
question but there's some economic value
in sense of contribution okay there's
the advancement of society so but but
one thing with the economic aspect is
that we're focusing on the value in
dollars right and it's something we can
quantify what I was doing but a lot of
the value for example that we produce in
academia isn't something that we can
quantify so easily and for example we
the amount of resources are getting from
grants doesn't depend on our site I
think I think that that at least the way
I was interpreting is that there's a
broader definition than just a dollar so
we were assuming away almost immediately
the dollar motivation are there other
things that are sort of somewhat scarce
that would continue to motivate us right
yeah so for example if I look at how we
are evaluating research especially maybe
in humanities but also in in science in
general it all it has a lot to do with
what is perceived by other humans that
it brings to society in terms of the the
common good or value to society which is
very hard to quantify and we do it all
the time and it kind of works right
recently but it could be accolades or
you know community yeah so there are
these other things and I think there's
an agenda to understand better those
other non-monetary motivations
I mean economists love the monetary ones
because you there's like you can put
numbers you can do math with them and
the other stuff is a lot harder for most
users I'm intrigued by this not to
prolong this so one is the wider dish
back on of value that we're talking
about also the conception of the age are
we're talking about if it's truly the
ager we
in its false sense it's probably
creating much of the knowledge - hmm
right right if it's if it's that kind of
AGI so that's why I think sometimes true
but round so the question therefore if
we're doing knowledge creation work what
form of that is that knowledge creation
let me just say there's a bunch of hands
here and I think we should this is a
really interesting conversation we
should have it but let's get some other
there's a hub out in the back corner
right there right there with next to
Mike yep so um it occurs to me that
there's a population but keep your
answers really yeah I mean questions
really short and we'll have to we can
try and get as many in as we can okay
there's there's a population that you
could look to you're talking about in
loco parentis right so look at children
mm-hmm so that's our model who wants
there's a mic over there yeah when we
project ourselves into a GI induce
Carissa T I kind of worry when we can
reproduce what we did with what Francis
Fukuyama did with liberal democracy
projecting a kind of and the history
part of what I heard only part of what I
heard because of the thought experiment
refers to that I think it's because it's
a thought experiment we have to project
ourselves but intuitively it's gonna
remain messy even with an abundance
that's for sure and it's not going to be
the end of history and if we project
ourselves that way we will history will
strike back a bit like we're seeing it
right now there is no free lunch and
what john maynard keynes projected in
the 30s because of you want what would
happen a hundred years laters did not
consider for example co2 emission and
the fact that global warming is really
endangering the very model of society
that had in mind so in a way projecting
ourselves into an HDI or post asia world
is more a practice than an ideology
which is not easy to do I know
you know that's expansion on something
we touched on too briefly which is even
if we have abundance on some dimensions
there may be scarcity on environmental
status compute and other other
dimensions that we need to worry about
right here and
I just love the trade question by James
and wouldn't you consider trade in
journals like putting some energy to
reduce your entropy and then put in some
energy to reduce my entropy over all the
entropy increases but shouldn't we
strive for making humans some sort of
form like of ox peaks and cow cow birds
for AGI to remain in business with them
no I I don't have an answer to you but
but I think I'm starting to thinking
about some way to construct societal
codependents in this system so we don't
devolve into unproductive behaviors but
that's a good session like that okay I
think we can maybe get two more
questions so right here I just wanted
you nort that I think it's interesting
that in these discussions definitely not
just this one I think we often bring up
the idea of creating art or creating
music things like this and we often I
don't think I've ever heard sports
mentioned like team sports competitive
sports yeah and maybe it's because we're
like intelligentsia and it's not classy
to care about sports but I'm interested
what you think about that is as an
answer to things like need for
competition need for community need for
meaning it seems like a lot of people
have turned to sports as a way of
expressing some of them or maybe violent
or competitive everyone agreeing I guess
some things are inherently human can
only be done a certain way so we're
gonna keep doing those ok can we get
over how about Stuart so I I sense a
conclusion that at interpersonal
services are going to be a big part of a
future but I would argue that it's still
going to be an economy because in many
cases there's an asymmetry so somebody
might like talk to Gillian but Gillian
might not like talk to that person quite
so much but she's willing to do it in
return for something that that other
person that person can provide something
else like you know a violin lesson right
so then we get to barter and then of
course as soon as you've got three
people you can't do barter than you do
right and and we're back to the same old
system except that the things that we
want from each other
are these interpersonal services that we
don't want the machine I don't want to
have lunch with a machine now and then
when you think about that you think well
how good are we at doing that we're very
good at producing cell phones and
microphones and screens and cars
we're totally hopeless at producing high
quality high value into personal
services we don't know how to do it we
don't have a science of it
we don't have an engineering of it we
don't teach people and credential eyes
and professionalize them to do it and
many of those professions are low status
low income right now as a result so if
people are going to have a meaningful
economic role with a meaningful useful
distribution of income then we're gonna
have to totally change our educational
system our science-based the way our
economy around these kinds of things
most people are going to be
self-employed in this future for example
so things are going to be very very
different from what they are now yes
there are things that we value of
interpersonal relations I'm not sure
that thinking about it as services is
the only way but I agree with you there
will be those kinds of those kinds of
economies what about this point that you
require money and I think that we
usually agree a lot or hear what love
what you said except I think you didn't
see a role for money and maybe he does I
I don't know I mean I can't guess the
way it's framed I can see yes there
could still be and this is related the
way that James was also expressing if
there are things that humans want that
other humans right provide that are not
provided or we don't want them provided
by machines and that's that's an economy
okay but I'm also a but that's also the
point about a community and a structure
a social structure that supports that so
we've been granted an extra couple
minutes so I think we need two more
really quick questions and then we're
gonna have to wrap up with some yeah
let's go here first and about a lot of
this doesn't seems be implicitly
promised on an assumption about human
nature somehow
is is fixing certain levels on values
and mindsets that are culturally learned
I mean there's been a couple of comments
to the contrary but I think there's
still a very strong assumption there yes
certainly there's always going to be
some competition in some cooperation but
are we are we selling ourselves too
short there should we have like more
emphasis be more open to evolving the
values and mind bets and in the role of
AI is in that there's I forget who
there's a quote from the east that says
that while the West was learning to
control matter the East was learning to
control mind and that you know we're
talking a lot about goal alignment what
about you know thinking about this more
in terms of values alignment and values
evolution we want to respond I mean I
I'd be delighted the more that's the
case I just have ended this the most the
people who most vociferous lee in a
political arena argue a it's all I
reminded values tend to be more
realpolitik great last question
thanks um so Stuart said he doesn't want
to have lunch with a robot and I
intuitively and my gut feels somewhat
similarly or I get his point but I think
it's on incorrect to assume that other
people will share that preference
especially if we're talking about a GI
which is superior to humans at doing
anything that humans can do a eyes might
be more engaging conversation partners
they might give better violin lessons so
on and so forth so I think especially if
we think about going really a lot
further into the future and beyond
current generations and people who are
alive and maybe already have some
sentimental attachment to interacting
with other humans I think it's actually
not clear that that's gonna remain
valued and I think that's something
that's worth thinking about um and it
might even be oppressive in some sense
to try and enforce people to value other
humans company if they find that they
really prefer the company of they eyes
agree
well I think you're not talking about
forcing anybody to decide that they have
to prefer lunch with a human to to a
machine I don't think we're talking
about that and I am also think about
like I think we don't only want to be
thinking of it in terms of producing
stuff or services it's the app the
expression the engagement you know I
like having conversations with people I
have lives and connections but it's not
just I want to have a good conversation
so anyway does it matter to you if you
know that it's a real person reverse the
stimulation that's better and more
interesting and more engaging I don't
know but I don't have I mean I have
history this is you know I have history
and relationships with people over time
and so I see them again and I want to
have a conversation I have an ongoing
life with them it's not just about the
consumption activity of a conversation I
have no idea how much I will enjoy
having a conversation with an AI but I'm
totally open to what might come offer an
analogy if you look at it for example
you look at a bunch of three-year-olds
five-year-olds they do like to interact
with adults but they also actually
interact with each other a lot right so
if you say well we get to super
intelligence and it's really so much
better than us from all these things I
suspect that it will still be a role but
we'd like to interact with each other
somewhat similar to like the
five-year-old at minimum all right
whatever this fear of these preferred
human history human activities done I
just hope the bit big enough to
occupying all of us yeah yeah I do know
that there are people I found out the
other day will pay $100,000 for Emma and
her maids bankers hand me this
specifically has a lot of human labour
into it and they would not pay that if
it were machine made I don't not my
preference is but there are at least
some people how many how many of these
they sell I don't know those people
how many those people know I don't know
if it's I don't know if it's enough to
employ everybody but there at least some
people who have a very strong preference
for you know genuine art as opposed to
repr
doctrines you know handmade this
personal that as opposed to things that
may be intrinsically are better or
indistinguishable so that you know I
don't know house where that value comes
from something we need to study more
but let me up let me wrap up by giving
you each a chance to make recommendation
or advice that you in has to be brief
but you have any thoughts about how we
get to the to the good scenarios that
we've heard on the on the panel and
avoid the bad scenarios go let's go
well it's gonna same order I suppose
okay so I'm gonna pick up on the Hermes
bag and the governance question and the
point that we don't know it anywhere
near enough about how human normative
governance structures work I think
that's probably a signaling system the
expensive bag by the way it totally
constructed maybe something to do with
status but we don't we don't have very
we have pretty naive ideas about how
those systems work and I think we mean
if we are going to figure out how to
develop the institutions the
organizations the structure that
navigate that complex process of what do
we do in a very very different world I
think we need to be study I think we
need to be every year decade that making
sure that we're having shadowed be
evolved involved with each other right
whether it's codependency or anything
else and whether it's jobs or anything
else so maybe we're gonna be inventing
you know thousands of new sports but you
know that I think that's an important
thing to pay attention to and make sure
as part of codependence and pollution
with you know between asking the
machines and been asking different of us
whether as people but as people in feet
and then second there's no way your
recognitions we should look for ways to
we should design find the guys that way
is dying whatever mechanisms put in such
to necessarily encourage interdependence
in codependence we should just find us
never can
Sandin
there's no way of way of avoiding some
distributional ubi plus I like it if
it's more conditioned on something that
incurred well that is paid and I am
convinced that Keynes was wrong that
economics is not going to end because
clearly as you're saying we we have a
lot of work to sort out the new ways
that we might be able to work in this
area where we're status and community
and human interaction may or may not be
important I think there's a lot of
unsolved open problems on glad I for a
little while we still have a job so
let's uh let's uh
thank the panel and
[Applause]
[Music]